I work with Santa Fe Tow we're on
rotation okay is this is it your car no
no I'm in the truck I didn't get hit or
nothing I just pulled over C
it are you hurt or
anything uh my hands are a little bit um
from the from the um that's you right
not
my from the I guess the airbag I'm not
too
sure okay you want be checked out just
wiped up just in case uh yeah how old
are you I'm uh 40 40
5 is it cool if I move my vehicle away
get ready so Trac load up bounce yeah
all right thank you sir I'm going to
back up guys 57 yeah yeah go
ahead
5 can you roll 55 for a 40y old her left
hand's a little banged up are the
other and this your car this is my car
free to copy
28 where she
at right
here she's got two little girls with two
little
kids over there yeah and Driver of what
this car
here
hi there how are you good where are you
going I'm going to my house okay your
car's over there though if if your car's
over there why you going here with your
kids well I'm trying to get home gotcha
gotcha do your fav put the kids in your
car walk over me no no no no please walk
over with
me don't worry like when I take it I
take it back to the
scene no we we are arresting then what
we do take him to the scene let's
go let go let
go let's go get up why are you pulling
me get up I am getting up ready I'll
help you up sorry I I didn't mean to
pull you ready 1 2 three up oh I want to
my kids no he'll take them over there no
my kids I promise you ma'am
don't I'm not well just walk
normal I am okay we'll talk over here I
promise you you trying to drag your kids
away one uh
two will you were you were you driving
this car this is your car okay so you
you and that car somehow made contact
right yeah I had a green light and these
people they noticed I had a green light
I had the right to go okay so got you
gotcha no no I'll talk to them okay so
you were heading westbound yes I was
heading westbound to for winds to go
pick up my friend gotcha and then this
car was going and then they this car was
going northbound
right but they FL me though go ahead sir
got you no I I totally get
that
10 for
[Music]
209 of cor 28 of boy Frank boy young 98
that's our vehicle we need
246s
okay why were you running away from the
scene if you got hit why did you run
away from the scene so scared what were
you what were you afraid
of my point was cuz my kids got taken
away from me when I wasn't doing nothing
wrong well I'm not here to take you I'm
not here to take your kids away
okay I'm here to investigate a crash and
then I hear oh the person involves is
running and I look and you're basically
dragging two little kids with you scared
or not is that the smart thing to do no
probably not right so don't worry your
your kids so you have to drag them back
over here we put them in a in a in a in
a police car where they're nice and safe
we we don't need kids out here running
right obviously there's already one
crash we don't need another crash
possibly injuring your kids do we yeah
okay so you're going to run that way and
you don't live here right you live
in right over there where you where do
you live at at the hotel what
hotel um Hilton right across um Four
Winds okay
so how much did you drink
tonight not that much okay what is not
that much to you not that much it's like
what a pint and beer okay so a pint and
a beer is what you had when did you have
I had enough to sub up and then I was
driving I had a green light gotcha I'm
not saying that you're have f for the
crash I never said that I ask you how
much you had to drink so you said you
had a pint and a beer when did you have
those two hours AG just so we're Square
you did not hit your head no did have
any major head injury no did you
graduate high school yes did college no
do you know the English alphabet yes do
you know the English number system yes
can you count backwards yes do you have
any problems walking balancing or
turning no okay put your heel and Toes
together hands at your sides and you
know why we're doing this right because
you admitted to consuming alcohol yes
okay I'm sorry about my hair's my way do
you have my hair tight no but you do it
on your right
wrist okay hands right sides see my
finger right here yes or no yes follow
my fingertip with your eyes only without
moving your head his hand's going to
move for your left to your right just
follow it the whole time you understand
what I want you to do yes what do I want
you to do you want me to look at your
finger okay and not move my head only my
eyes yes here we
go up ready follow it I'll make it
pretty easy for you
okay I'm not a very good artist but do
you see that thing that should be a
circle hat your sides follow that circle
with your eyes look at it the whole time
[Music]
okay
here
here sorry I'm my phone don't worry
country hand your sides country my
finger
okay same thing I'm going to go up and
down just follow follow with this my
finger
I no that that you don't have shoes on
no I don't can you can you walk Barefoot
for nine
steps yeah come over here there's no
glass no no there's no glass all the
glass is over there come over here right
here on my
light put your he heeling toes together
face no face that way has heels and Toes
together like this heels and Toes hands
on your sides
okay can you imagine a straight line in
between you and I yes okay the line
width will be the width of your foot
which is about 4 in wide do you
understand that 4 in 4 in wide oh
roughly roughly the line will be the
width of your foot which is your foot's
about four inches
wide can you imagine a straight line in
between you and I yeah okay
do me a favor on that on that imaginary
line place your left foot just like this
going to do it for me now NOP that's
your right foot place your left foot
okay okay now place your right foot
directly in front of your left so you he
the toe like I'm doing go do that for me
now right foot in front of left hands on
your sides up don't start walking end up
end up in this position right foot in
front of left nope right right there
hands on your sides do not move until I
take you do you understand yes or no yes
okay get back in the position you miss
Chino you have to stay in this position
right here yes
okay for that position when I tell to
begin and only when I tell to begin
you'll take nine heel toe steps down
that imaginary line get back in that
position say like that get in this
position like like me okay don't move
okay just like this don't start yet no
don't start yet watch me one two three
three you will take nine steps once you
make nine steps you will make a turn
keep your front foot tted on the ground
with your back foot bringing around like
this taking a series of small steps
turning all the way around get back in
that
position and then come back this way get
back in the
position did you un the Turning process
yeah okay after you turn and then go
like get back in that position yeah
right foot in front of left stay like
that right foot in front of left okay
don't move okay turn you'll take nine
more steps down that same line just like
this one don't start yet two three back
down number nine get back to that
position the starting position right
foot in front of left okay this test
keep your hands right at your sides look
down at your feet while you count and
count l so you can hear you also once
you start this test don't stop that
you've completed it and don't forget to
touch he toe in every single step any
questions for me do you fully understand
yes I understand but I just got to crash
so I totally understand that I I totally
understand that I don't want to mess up
on the test CU okay you know I don't
know you see this shit right here well
actually that there's just a little teen
scratch and looks like it's old no that
that then again then again I'm not a
doctor but I asked you you had any major
head injury I if you hit your head you
told me no okay put your right foot in
front of your
left right foot in front of left okay
next step will be step number one go
ahead and
begin
okay
round one 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 okay face me yes two toes
together yes hands are your sides right
here next test called the oneel leg
stand okay when I tell you to begin what
I want you to do is raise the leg your
choice either your left leg or your
right leg approximately 6 in parallel
with the ground do you know what the
word parallel means uh like level yes
okay let's say this is the ground this
it's like going like this no not like
that but I will show you what I what I
want okay uh 6 in roughly about the size
of a coat can watch
me real quick is it okay if we assess
your children for
injuries okay thank you thank okay M my
sides okay don't sry yet just watch me
what I'm going to do is is I'm going to
raise my left foot okay don't start yet
my left foot is full extended both feet
are straight my foot's about six inches
par parallel with the ground which means
level r on my sides once your foot is
raised look down that foot and begin to
count like this 1001 1002 13 1004 1005
just keep on Counting until I try to
stop counting ma during this test keep
your hands direct at your sides
look down at the foot that's raised and
count down we can hear you any questions
no you fully understand yes okay you
start when you want I'll tell you when
to
start well what can I start whenever you
want ready yes I'm ready go ahead start
begin,
1,2,3
shit,
456 all say stop counting keep counting
oh sorry I thought you said count to
1,000 just keep on Counting and take to
stop keep
going can I restart you want test over
yes ready and reset this and begin go
ahead1
now8
1565 what
ST
do you know your do you know the English
alphabet yes okay starting with the
letter H stopping at the letter R recite
them forward but don't sing them say
each letter clearly so I could hear you
recite between H and R right yes go
ahead Jake k out m o p q
u and tell me not to say R right is that
what I said yes okay I don't remember
saying that but okay yes can you can you
count backwards yes 58 to 43
backwards start at 58 stop at 43
backwards go
ahead 57
56 50 I'm sorry 57
55 5 4 53 5 53 52 51
50 49
45 44 or
54 5
sorry I'm sorry what did you say okay
come with
me one hand here one hand
there right put both hands behind your
back both hands both hands behind your
back leave them there well I'll give you
your phone here to bit
okay I'm I'm I'm going to put two cups
on you
okay give me right now I'm place you
under arrest okay step off meing off who
else in the vehicle uh Rubble who else
is in the vehicle just him just you two
yes sir okay do you have your lense on
you yes why you going so
fast cuz I trying to get to work trying
to get get to work yeah where do you
work
at High Street Central High Street okay
why you pulling here then because I saw
you me or what look CU I saw you and I
was like you're 73 on Montgomery I'm
sorry I saw you I I swear to God I saw
you okay who whose car is this it's his
car his car yes sir you want no you're
good where you guys coming from right
now uh uh hold on it's it's something
Loca it's right there on Louisiana and
Montgomery
Loos Locos no Cantina Cantina yeah I
don't know what that is it's so you know
where the gas station's at Montgomery or
what um s
Louisiana Montgomery Louisiana uh I
don't know what it is it's kind of new
it's kind of new like a little Mexican
like typee shit okay all right
um you say you're heading to work yes is
that the truth yes okay and I've been
drinking yeah I know you've been
drinking that's my second question how
much how much Al you consume we had like
three shots three shots of what yes
uh you drank three shots yes sir and
then she he drank three shots he drank
more he drank more this is his car I'm
driving okay like and I told him I could
get a room because obviously I got a
hotel okay all right so um you're doing
73 on Montgomery sir okay and you try
and you're speeding here
me okay I'm going to make sure you're
safy Drive okay all right I just can't
wear these shoes because they're B all
right no big deal just h t okay okay
cool just see how your head straight
right there is just keep it straight
okay see tip my finger follow that with
your eyes only okay keep your head
downest sorry my eyes are getting dry
cuz my eyelashes you can blink it's okay
for you my eyes are getting dry it's
okay for you to BL want me to go to
47 stand
by keep your head down right there
sorry my eyes are dry for your I'm I'm
sorry I already know how this that works
it's like jittery and I'm like okay just
keep your eyes open you go it's okay for
you to Blink okay over here
where
there I fucked up honestly you're good
you're doing good keep your keep your
hands on your side
sorry
I'm cold as fuck I'm sorry I'm
cold
my eyelashes I'm sorry I cannot see as
far as you can
okay okay put your things back on
sandles back on sorry if I had my
eyelashes off I could take them off if
you want you good just H behind your
vehicle H TI right there don't grab
anything just stand okay can I just give
me a sec yeah just give me a second okay
give me a
second yeah yeah I said
yeah yeah
good let's walk over
here she going to be on my ass like this
is
officer look this is the officer
Monique
so just letting you know cuz I told him
I need to call
you so just letting you know okay what
the hell happened I was going 73 on
a
35 be here well okay listen I'm just
calling you to let you know okay love
you bye okay you put your phone right
here for
me you want to put it back in your purse
I don't want that to slide or somebody
to grab it no okay walk over here for
me
see where my letter is stand right there
for me all right right there face that
way for me all right put your feet
together can I take off my shoes yeah
you can take over your shoes well cuz
these are really good all right put your
feet together hands down to your side
you say no major injuries for your legs
you can walk balance turn I have like a
to spit that's about it but can you walk
balance turn okay all right can you
imagine a straight line in front of you
if there's a straight line here for me
the straight line well I can't do it
because of the unit okay but can you
imagine can you imagine straight lineing
for you about just straight okay okay
I'm going to have you put your left foot
on that line and then put your right
foot in front of your left foot touching
heel to toe touching Heel To Toe Okay
Miss ma' ma'am yeah I I didn't say
walk just follow my instructions okay
can you no can you imagine a straight
line in front of you about the width of
your foot yeah okay put your left foot
in front of you and then put your right
foot in front of your left foot touching
Heel To
Toe sorry
sorry oh my God just follow my
instructions okay sorry all right so put
your right foot in front of your left
foot put your right foot in front of
your Left Foot Right There and hands
down to your
side
chus I I didn't say walk oh I'm sorry
just just follow my instructions okay
that's okay go put your feet together
okay now just follow my instructions
okay I'm going to give you detail
instructions okay put your right foot in
front of your left foot touching Heel To
Toe right there hands down to your side
and you're going to stay in that
position until I tell you to move okay
on this imaginary line about the width
of your foot you're going to walk nips
forward touching Heel To Toe on every
step looking at your toes the entire
time keeping your hands and arms down to
your side at all times and count out
loud for me in every step yes sir okay
once you get on your ninth step leave
that forward foot plant in the ground
with your back foot you're going to take
a series of small steps you're going to
turn around and do nine steps back
touching Heel To Toe looking at your
toes the whole time keeping your hands
and arms down to your side at all times
and count out alloud for me in every
step do you understand that yes sir okay
all right stay in that position till I
tell you to move okay so we're in this
position right I'm going to show you the
test oh this way stay in that position
put your right foot in for your left
foot put your right foot right there I'm
going to show you the test okay so we're
in this position right yes so what I'm
going to have you do is you're going to
go one
two three I only demonstrated three but
you're going to do nine yes okay once
you get once you get on your ninth step
leave that for foot plant on ground do
you if I put my hands on my back put
them down to your side I and then with
your back foot take a series of small
steps okay turn around and do nice steps
back okay one
two three okay touching Heel To Toe on
every step looking at your toes the
whole time keep your hands and arms down
to your side at all times and count all
loud for me in every step do you
understand that okay do you have any
questions okay put your right foot in
front of your left foot one okay no go
back I'm sorry you two you're good put
your right foot in front your left foot
okay that's going to be the starting
position okay do you have any questions
no sir do you understand the test yes
sir it's very important M once you start
the test do not stop until you're done
understand I'm going to record okay you
may begin
one 2 3 4
5 6 7
8 sorry already failed it you can turn
around start stop start start from there
turn
around and do nice his back one two
three four five six
seven8 n okay put your like first I'll
stand over here for me oh my God right
there stand right there for me face me
face me put your feet together hands
down to your side all right M you're
going to lift one leg of your choice
your right or left leg it doesn't matter
to me okay approximately 6 inches off
the ground okay your both legs are going
to be straight your foot's going to be
parallel to the ground par parallel
means level to the floor your hands and
arms are going to be down to your side
at all times you're going to be looking
at that raised foot and count allowed in
a series of a th001 1,002 1,003 and
you're going to keep going until I tell
you to stop okay do you understand that
yes sir okay I'm going to go and
demonstrate it for you okay I can't I
can't sound put your feet together okay
face that way for me right there all
right I'm going to go and demonstrate
for you okay so we're in this position
right so lift left the leg of your
choice okay approximately six in St
watch me watch me watch me approximately
six in off the ground your hands and
arms are going to be down to your side
both legs are going to be straight your
foot's going to be level to the floor
you're going to be looking at that
raised foot and you're going to count
out loud 1,001 1,002 1,003 1,004 you're
going to keep going until I tell you
stop I didn't tell you to start you're
good good just follow my instructions
okay do you understand the test yes sir
do you have any questions no sir okay
it's very important once you start it do
not stop until you're done yes sir until
I tell you to stop okay do you
understand that yeah okay I'll let you
know when to
begin all right M you may begin when
you're ready1
17890 2011 2012 2013 2014 2015 2016
2017 keep going sorry sir I can't keep
going I I lose Bal is there another test
I can do yeah of course do you want to
stop this one yes yeah put your sandal
back
on all right I'm going to R you some
other tests okay he's not going to
you're not going to be able to walk
bounce or nothing like that okay we're
going to stand in front of my vehicle
just don't touch my vehicle or lean on
my vehicle
okay just it's you're good face me face
Mr all right you said how old are you 24
yes sir what's your highest level of
Education uh 12th so you graduate done
right there you graduate from high
school okay do you know your numbers
from 0 to 100 yes do you know your your
English alphabetical letters from A
through Z yes okay I'm going to have you
reset a certain amount of numbers not
through not backwards no no I'm going to
explain to you okay I'm going to have
you recite a certain amount of numbers
and a certain amount of letters okay the
numbers are going to be backwards the
alphabetical letters are going to be
forward okay I can't even recite them
alphabetical letters backwards I've seen
this I'm like I cannot do backwards okay
so you're going to start at the number
57 okay start at 57 count backwards to
three and stop okay start at 57 count
backwards to 38 and stop do you
understand that yes okay can you do it I
think okay you want to try it yeah okay
57 56 count backwards to 38 and stop do
you understand that you have any
questions no okay you may begin 56 55 54
53 52 51 50 48 47 46 46 4 45 44 43 42 41
40 49 or 39 38 37 36
35 34
36 done I'm sorry I'm cold you good okay
uh in your English your English alphabet
okay I'm not going to have you reset it
backwards you're going to reset it
Forward okay you're going to start at
the letter H and you're going to reset
every alphabetical letter forward to the
letter R do not sing the alphabet just
reset every letter all l could hear you
start at h h i j k l o p k r done yes
okay okay and then what hand what's your
Domin hand right your right hand okay
watch me don't start the test okay
you're going to start with your pinky
your thumb Don't touch don't start it
just watch me okay start with your
pinking your thumb you're going to touch
your index fingers okay you're going to
go one 2 3 4 4 okay 4 3 2 1 that's one
pass yes sir I need add three times I'm
going to show you that okay 1 2 4 4 3 2
1 that's one pass three times sir do you
understand that yes sir you have any
questions no sir okay you may be it 4 3
2 1 4 3 2 1 4 two one okay all right
vehicle for me yes sir B it back for
me all right M it is uh 12:23 a.m. okay
you are going to be place under arrest
for driving one of the influence of
intoxicated liquor and or drugs okay I
don't see any pockets on you do you have
anything that you're concealing
uh yes sir just in my purse in your
purse yes what do you have in your purse
uh no no not ciling just in my purse is
just my purse my phone oh okay no I'm
saying on your person oh no okay you
have nothing in your shirt in said your
pants or anything that I should know of
no okay all right sit down right here
for me sit down yeah right there oh you
know what it's it's pretty cold walk
over here walk over here I'm going to
put you back here yeah my phone don't
forget my phone no no I don't I never
forget your phone my phone
spend okay come over here have a seated
for me move my hair yeah honestly please
like no like more like on my face oh on
your face yes and on the side got more
hair know sorry on my other side to like
okay there okay no no I'll fix it for
you let me put your okay how you doing
man I'm also went to Mexico State Police
I know I was going too fast I go to the
bathroom wa too fast how fast you think
you were going uh
75 I'm so sorry I just really need to
poop I'm just trying to get home I do
apologize 95 miles hour I'm so sorry
okay and then you're wobbly you're all
over the place okay you have a driver's
license so what Drew my attention to
your vehicle was literally when you got
on to I25 from Jefferson driving I know
and you made the wide radius turn and
then literally was like I'm a driver I
do apologize I'm so sorry do you have
insurance uh
yes well it's all my ex-husbands I
actually like don't have it so if you
want to give me a ticket and I go to
court and look up how you pronounce your
last
name I'm gonna have you step on out real
quick I just have to ask for more
questions any weapons on you on your
person okay want step on out I've never
been in trouble before like if you just
give me a ticket please I'm a good girl
I just step on out of the vehicle
please someone have you watch to the
front of my unit for me please
okay so why did you say you're a good
girl and all that what do you I've never
been in trouble I'm just trying to get
home cuz I just really okay so what are
you trying to tell me yeah I'm just
trying to go home listen I want you to
be honest with you how much have you had
to drink tonight a couple of drinks
what's a couple of drinks um St right
here two
redos last um probably 20 30 minutes can
you describe the size just a regular can
you describe them a short please don't
arrest me I've never been arrested
before let me like 30 minutes 20 30
minutes and then where was that at
um craft repu you head no sir do you
wear I yes sir can you you have them on
right now they soft or heart there so
okay can you put your feet together just
like mine hands are let side we need to
remain in that position there do you
understand mhm I'm going have you st at
the tip of my right index finger with
your eyes pick me up listen please we're
not to that point yet listen I have
someone who can take me home you listen
okay I'm not going to sit here and you
know argue I don't like to argue I
really don't okay so listen I need you
to stare at the tip of my right index
finger with your eyes and do not move
your head you understand you have any
questions no you see my finger right
here P my finger with your eyes and do
not move your head do you understand
follow my finger
please
my finger
my you're not even looking at my finger
what yeah can please can I just have my
friend pick me no please no listen we're
not even to the point of
what my friend was following me can so
listen are you going to cooperate with
my test yeah just relax take a deep
breath I know I up listen I'm just
trying to get home take a deep breath
relax you're how
old you're 30 years old okay so we're
the same age act the same age okay I
done nothing go cool with you okay I
don't need you to you know get all you
know emotional and start yelling and all
that I'm not going to do I'm not going
to act irrational I'm just telling you I
got you listen that I have a DD that can
pick me up I got you listen you made the
decision to drive you're driving
horrible right arrest me I'm not even to
that point I don't want to arrest you I
really don't but listen I have to do my
job you can respect that right can can
someone just pick me up we're not do
that we're not calling anybody we're not
having tra I need to do my job what I'm
trying to do is make sure you're safe to
drive you understand stay right here for
me please do not V for
me don't move from there
please go walk over here for
please walk over here please please
please please please please please
please please being silly right now I'm
listen listen I'm going through a
divorce I I don't have the money to get
out please are you saying you don't feel
like you should be driving right now is
that what you're saying is I would
rather just leave in my car and have
someone pick up I ask you a question I
am good in my eyes but I really don't
want in your eyes to so what I'm trying
to do right now listen what I'm trying
to do is to make sure you're safe to
drive if you're safe to drive you're
going to be on your way okay
not if you're not I'm going to have to
do my job and you're going to go to jail
but we're not to that point please sir
please here you can't give me a chance
to pick me up please put please pleasee
officer I can't I I I can't lose my son
I'm like 2 minutes from my house can you
listen to me can you listen to me yes or
no please
listen we are trying okay you but but
you just can't just have my friend
picked me up no we're you're right pass
you decided to get inside your vehicle
and you decided to drive away then
ultimately you drove like crap and
that's why I'm here
okay but but can I get out for free
tomorrow what are you talking about I
don't even saying you're going to jail
okay okay okay okay I just have never
been in trouble and I don't know how to
act act like an adult that that's
probably the first thing you can start
doing you're 30 years old act like a 30y
old face me
put your feet together hands reg at your
side follow my finger with your eyes and
do not move your head do you understand
yes or no follow my finger
please okay if you have any injuries to
your legs or feet they're going to
prevent you from walking bouncing or
turning are you healthy that's okay
those shoes comfortable walking I see
that they have a little Hill to them
about a 2in hill would you like to
remove them like to keep them
up do you have any other flat sold shoes
inside your
vehicle have you stand right here facing
your
vehicle stop right there face your
vehicle can you picture an imaginary
line on the ground from where your left
foot is straight out in front of you to
my right foot can you picture a straight
line on the ground yes or
no okay this line is going to be
approximate the width of your shoe do
you understand
that the width of my shoe yep yeah the
line's going to be approximate the width
of your shoe do you understand yeah all
right Ma so listen I'm going to need you
to put your left foot on that line take
your right foot place it directly in
front of your left foot touching Hill to
toe you see how I'm standing yep just
like that I don't even know if I can do
that normally but I will try my best can
you keep your hands right the side ma'am
I'm going to need you to remain in that
position there till I'm going give you
all the instructions you will not start
the test till I tell you to do so do you
understand yes or no yes are you shaking
your head yes or I can can't see so yes
you okay so put your right foot directly
front your left
foot so not until I tell you to do so
ma'am you're going to take nine steps
forward on this imaginary line you're
going to look downward at your feet
count each step out loud touch Hill to
toe on each step your hands right the
side at all times do you have any
questions so far so look I'm going to
demonstrate this test to you man it's
going to look like this ma one take a
step back I didn't tell you to start yet
like that take a step back put your
right foot directly in front of your
left foot
stop right there so look I'm going to
demonstrate stay just like that one two
three see how I did that I'm only going
to take three steps you're going to take
nine steps do you understand
yeah bance already on your ninth step
your front foot's going to stay planted
on the ground with your back foot which
is your opposite foot you're going to
take a series of small steps just like
so to turn yourself OPP Direction s what
i s I'm going to do nine steps and then
do a turn yes go and put your right foot
directly in front of your left foot stop
right there
so once again you're going to look like
this you're going to leave your front
foot planted with your right foot you're
your with your opposite foot you're
going take a series of small steps and
turn yourself in the opposite direction
just like so at the end of nine steps
yes okay you have any questions on the
Turing process I'm going to do my best
now you're going to be facing to the
front of my patrol you proceed back nine
steps like so one so you want me to go
that way and come this way three correct
you're going to take nine steps forward
turn around take nice hold on hold on oh
wait I thought you wanted me to go and
turn this way stay right there okay St
right there ma'am ma'am stand right here
okay and face your vehicle oh okay right
fo confused I thought you wanted me to
go toward yours no worries right foot
directly in front of your Left
Foot Right Foot directly in front your
left
foot I'm sorry I
seriously I just don't want to up
because I
don't I'm so I'm literally right there
I'm literally right there and I'm scared
yeah no I'm good I'm good I just don't
want to up cuz I'm scared don't wor put
your right foot directly in front of
your left foot do you have any questions
regarding the instructions or you
completely understand everything I
understand once you start do not
stop
you want me to go
back that's just me be can I try
again just
nervous okay can you stand right here
for me please sorry put your just like
mine
hands facing
me I'm going to need you remain in that
position there you're not going to start
the test Side Tire to do so do you
understand yes sir so not Side Tire to
do so you're going to take the foot of
your choice either your right foot or
your left foot you're going to lift that
foot approximately 6 in from the ground
you going keep your foot parallel to the
ground you keep your hands right side
both legs straight you're going to look
down at your raised foot you're going to
count in upward Man by
1 coun upward by 10000 and TI TIG you
want to count to a th000 you're going to
count by 1,00 1,001 1,002
and continue counting upward by 1000
until I Tire to stop so look I'm going
to demonstrate this test to you it's
going to look like this I'm going pick
my right fo for my demonstration but you
can pick your right or your left you
understand that foot approximately 6 in
from the ground you see how I'm doing so
uhhuh you keep your foot parallel to the
ground do not point up this is parallel
do you understand yes sir hands are
glitch side both legs straight looking
down at your raised foot you're going to
count an upper Man by 1,00 so this 1001
1002 1003 continue counting upward by
1000 until I tell you to stop you have
any question I'm sorry it's called you
have any questions no sorry you can do
yes sir go and begin
[Applause]
[Music]
ma'am I don't have balances it
is can I try this way CA off
please going
stop I'm going to have you walk to the
front of my uniform please are you going
to arrest me straight to the front
bumper just walk to the front bumper you
going to arrest me we're going to talk
over there ma' can you please walk over
there please please give me a second
please give me a second don't put your
hands on your back please no sir don't
resist them no I can't can I can I let
somebody know well I'll have somebody
call go and walk I don't know anybody
I'll give you your cell phone you're
going to call here in a minute oh you
serious yes ma'am can I
tonight is that a possibility yes yeah
not me tonight this like right now but
this morning it's going to be this
evening like this evening I have to go
to work unfortunately you're not going
to make it there your sh right now
sorry you're going to get me yes you're
going to have your cell phone can't pick
me up now no ma the time is I have to
wait please give me another chance
please please please please sir please
I'll do
anything why can't you give me another
chance why can't I fcked up if I have a
safe ride
home
why if I have a safe I don't understand
why you can't you anything going to stab
me Po why can't you just let me have
someone pick me up pass that man listen
do you have anything that's going to
stand me poke Harmon any you have
anything on your nothing at all wa is my
car going to be okay going to give toad
man I'm going to have to pay $200 you're
going to have to pay to get it out yes
ma'am I don't know how much it's going
to be sir please give me a chance please
please I I why because you're you're
arrested that's why I've never even been
arrested like I don't understand what
I'm down the road from my
house I what what time did
someone what time someone pick me up all
depends on the judgment on the judge
yes walk can you open your mouth pleas
please yeah tongue out do you have
anything in your mouth you drink no
anything El your teeth in your
gums they're not going to be me stried
down right I'm just going to be in the
tank can I have my phone when I'm in
there now when you're in the tank but
yes you can have your phone before
before but I have what time can I get
picked up it all depends on the jve have
a seat please I need to go to I need to
go to work in the morning I will do my
best to make sure you get to work man I
need to be there at 7 I don't know about
that man since it's already 2:00 in the
morning are you serious want me back
please so man listen to me I'm about to
tell you something important you under
arrest for driving one of them
I've been talk am I going to get a an
interlock that's up to the Judgment
listen so this is my please dude I I'm
going through div and I don't have any
money I don't have any money and I have
my son I'm literally I can't I will be
homeless I'm sorry ma'am listen I have
to redo this why could you just let my
friend pick me up how it works listen to
me I'm about to tell you something
important you were under arrest for
driving one of the influence of intoxic
liquor and or drugs can I please have my
phone the new
Mexican requires you to submit to a
breath test to determine the alcohol
content your my phone after you take our
test my phone can you please right to
choose an additional independent test
can you please give me my pH not right
now not right now okay I need my phone I
will bring it with us you don't you're
not going to have it right now in the
back and my car is going to be towed it
is yes I can't lose my job you take test
any syy independent test I've never been
in trouble okay we'll read
later have a phone call before we head
to the jail you said I could have a
couple of phone calls yes I'll let you
have a couple phone calls before we go
to jail so like like can I just call
them now I can't hear you why can't I
just call them now and let them
know I don't know how this works you act
like I've been arrested before I don't
know anything and I've explained to you
multiple times
vaguely
vaguely I don't know anything about
this I don't know any of the process I
don't know what happens I don't know
anything well you're going to get booked
into the jail
okay and then go a judge and get
released but you have no idea how long
it's going to take
dep okay so it could be 5:00
tomorrow fan fucking tastic Monday I
can't I I can't I literally cannot sit
here until Monday I will lose my fucking
apartment I have a
kid I literally just and I'm going
through a divor I cannot sit here until
Monday I can't I will lose lose my job
I'm sorry you're not I really am you
could have let my friend pick me up you
could have I was going to ride with him
and I didn't want my car you could have
given me a
break you know that I you could have
given me a break I understand that it's
your job but you could have let my
friend pick me up and I would to pick my
car up tomorrow and now I'm fucked I
know that's not your
problem but you could have just let my
friend pick me up here for
me wa just stand right in front of my
patrol vehicle all right you have no
knives weapons on you huh you have any
knives or weapons or anything on you
okay I just want to make sure you're
putting your hands in your pocket so you
can relax it's okay all right brinie you
said you're coming from from where again
third and Central third and Central so
JC's New York Pizza Department that's
literally in between second and Central
and third in central okay all right so
the reason I pulled you out of the
vehicle okay there's you and there's
three other people on the vehicle no
okay I am smelling a strong odor of
alcohol emitting from the vehicle yeah
okay who's been drinking um passenger
and the two in the backy I haven't you
have not consumed any alcohol today all
day today um just be honest no nothing I
don't think so what do you mean you
don't think is no like I haven't you
haven't okay want to stand right here my
where my light is all right face me put
your feet together just like this and
hands down to your side all right go and
remove your glasses you can hang them
right here on your
I can't see without my glass I'm not
going to have you walk or anything I'm
just saying yeah I'm not going to I'm
not going to have you walk um this
side's broken because of my kids so okay
oh you put in your pocket yeah I'm just
letting you
know all right B any major hit injuries
no I just have a stigmatism in this left
eye so I can't do side to side okay well
you can follow my finger side to side
well I can okay you have a you have a
sign ISM your left eye yeah okay put
your hands down to your side all right
any major head injuries no no okay keep
your head straight
okay you see the tip of my finger yeah
follow that with your eyes only
[Applause]
okay
all right bnie so I'm ask you again how
much Alo you can okay then why am I
smelling old vka right now that we're
talking face to face none yeah honestly
okay all right have a seat stand right
here for me that's fine have it stand
right here and don't move from there
okay
that's Bry walk over here for me you
could put your glasses back
on
all right stand right here for me where
my light is and face the rear the rear
of your vehicle all right I see that
you're wearing uh sandals yep do you
feel comfortable walking in those
sandles that's fine okay do you have any
major problems with your legs anything I
got nerve damage and a hip rotation so I
can't do the foot to toe like this okay
but that's fine I can walk a straight
line if you want me to okay well let me
finish my question first okay do you
have anything going to stop you from
walking balancing or turning yeah cuz I
have a major hip rotation and I've gone
through physical therapy with it so I
can't walk the straight cuz I can't put
my heel to
to so can you can you walk in a straight
line uh if you really want me to sure
okay you want to sure okay just so I can
get home sure that's all we're trying to
do right I just want to make sure you're
safe to drive yeah no I'll do any test
you want me to I don't care perfect okay
that's all ask okay all right Bry can
you imagine a straight line in front of
you yeah about the width of your foot
okay put your left foot in front of you
then put your right foot in front of
your left foot touch your heel to
toe right there hands down to your side
and do not move from there okay do not
move from there all right you're going
to walk nine steps forward touching Heel
To Toe looking at your toes the whole
time keeping your hands down to your
side at all times and count out loud for
me in every step nine okay count out
loud for me in every step okay once you
get on your ninth step you're going to
leave that forward foot plant to the
ground foot take a series of small steps
and turn around and do nine steps how
many am I allowed to turn around there's
no there it doesn't matter as long as
you do a small steps I'm going to show
you two okay once you turn around you're
going to do the exact to show me I I
have to show you okay okay there's a
there's a there's a series that I have
to do okay all right let me finish what
I'm saying okay once you turn around
you're going to do nine steps back touch
your heel to toe looking at your toes
the whole time keeping your hands down
to your side at all times and count out
loud for me in every step do you
understand that okay I'm going to show
you the test okay all right Bry we're in
this position right get back in the
position I told you to we're in this
we're in this position right yes sir all
right all you're going to do is one two
three I did three you're going to do
nine once you get on your ninth step
leave that forward foot plant to the
ground with your back foot take a series
of small steps and turn around just like
this and and do nine steps back touching
Heel To Toe
one two three I did three you're going
to do nine yes sir okay do you
understand yes sir do you have any
questions right now okay it's very
important Bry once you start start the
test do not stop until you're done do
you understand yes sir okay do you have
any questions no okay if you have no
questions you may
begin
2 3
6 okay all right go stand right there
for me face me put your feet together
just like this hands down to your side
all right Bry so you're going to LIF the
leg of your choice you're going to have
to right leg or you could lift your left
leg it doesn't matter to me I'm going to
fail so you might as well put me in okay
do you want to do the test I just want
to make sure you're safe to drive okay
I'm going to fail cuz it's cold so I
don't care you have a jacket on I don't
have a jacket you see how I have BS it
doesn't matter so I'm going to fail so
you let me let me explain the test to
you how about that I already know so
hold like
6 you're you're everywhere just all I'm
very aggressive cuz I'm mad don't be mad
cuz I know that I'm not drunk and if I
go down to the station I'm going to blow
a 00 okay so then you're going to
release me and it's going to be for
nothing okay I'm not I'm I'm not are
just trying to do the standardize f bra
test I know I'm just cold so and I'm
anemic and I don't do it okay you want
to you want to try it go for it okay put
your feet together all right hands down
to your side all right so you're going
to lift the leg of your choice okay
approximately 6 6 in off the ground
about the size of a Cen your legs going
to be straight your foot's going to be
paralleled to the the ground parallel
means level to the floor your hands are
going to be down to your side at all
times you're going to be looking at that
raised foot and you're going to count
out loud a series of a,1 1,002 1,003 and
so forth until I try to stop do you
understand okay I'm going to show you
we're in this position right so you're
going to lift the leg of your choice
okay approximately 6 inches off the
ground your hands are going to be down
to your side at all times your leg's
going to be straight your foot's going
to be paralleled to the ground you're
going to be looking at that foot and
count out loud 1,001 1,002 1,003 and so
forth until I tell you to stop do you
understand yes do you have any questions
okay all right you may be again when
you're
ready 1001 1002
10031 112
12234 okay you can stop all right all
right BR you say you have a rotation
what what was wrong with your your hip I
have I got in car accident when I was 16
years old I have a rotator P this so I
can't do details okay we're walk over
here what's your highest level of
Education uh I got my GED and then I
tried to get my
full but just don't lean on my unit um I
didn't finish college so technically
college do you know your numbers from 1
0 to 100 yeah do you know your Alpha bit
from a through z not backwards no no I'm
not going to have you saying backwards I
can't even say backwards yeah I was okay
but you know your English alphabet yeah
okay and then what's your dominant hand
right your right hand okay I'm going to
give you a certain amount of numbers and
a certain amount of letters okay so the
the numbers I'm going to have you recite
is starting at the the number 56 count
backwards to 39 and stop okay okay start
at 56 count backwards to 39 and stop do
you understand that yeah do you have any
questions right now no okay you may
begin 56 57 58
uh did you
forget 58 57 56 55 54 53 52 51 50 49 48
47 46 45 44 43 42 41 40 39 38 37 36 cool
all right and then your English alphabet
all right I'm not going to have you
recite it backwards you're going to
recite It Forward okay start at the
letter H recite every alphabetical
letter forward to the letter R okay okay
H2 R 4 R do not sing the alphabet just
recite every letter out loud so I can
hear hear you okay H forward to R do you
understand that do you have any
questions no you may begin h i j k l m n
o p q r okay and then you say your which
is your dominant hand right right okay
I'm going to take off my gloves so you
can see me okay just watch me for right
now you're going to start with your
pinking I have carpal tunnel so I can't
touch can you do with can you do it with
that hand I can do it with this okay I'm
going to show you just watch me all
right so you're going to touch your
index fingers okay Touch starting with
your pinking your thumb you're going to
go one two three four M 4 3 2 1 that's
one pass I do that three times let me
show you that one more time okay 1 2 3 4
4 3 2 1 that's one pass and three times
okay do you have any questions no do you
understand the test yes okay you may
begin 4 3 2 1 1 2 3 4 4 3 2
1 1
4 3 2
1 1 2 3
4 4 3 2
1 2 okay go face my vehicle for
me all right bnie see you going be
placed under arrest for driving one of
the influen and talk to the Dicker and
her drugs DWI okay it is 10:29 p.m. okay
have a seat right there for
me all right B I'm going to go and read
something to you okay all I need is
Miranda it's not it's not it's not your
Miranda Rights okay so just listen to
me right okay just no it's not your Mand
RS all right just listen to me okay
listen to me I'm about to tell you
something important you're under arrest
for driving while under the influence of
intoxicated liquor and or drugs DWI the
New Mexico and pl syak requires you to
submit to a breath test to determine the
alcohol content of your blood after you
take our test you have the right to
choose an additional independent test if
you choose to take this additional
independent test you have the right to a
reasonable opportunity to arrange for a
physician a licensed nurse or laboratory
technician or technologist who is
employed by a hospital or physician of
your own choice to perform a addition
chemical test the cost of this
additional test will be paid by the law
enforcement agency which is the New
Mexico State Police so I'm asking you do
you agree to take our test which I'm
asking for a breath test yes okay open
your mouth for me wide open pick up your
tongue anything your mouth other than
your tongue in your teeth no okay
10:31 just a tongue Mar so yeah no I
know you just have to document yeah all
right come here all right face my
vehicle no face my vehicle face my
vehicle over here in the front right
here in the front separate your
feet I got the phone and I think my wall
okay but that's
it you have nothing on you no all right
come on I think I put it all in
my
or just watch your step
okay all right have you seen in there
for
[Music]
me hour and a half good so again the
reason for the Stop was uh your speed
and then when I got behind you isway
Lane so okay uh how approach of the
vehicle a uh Ober containers in the C
console um also hold of
alcohol pull you out also still
defecting that Li of alcohol your ad
Mission drink four uh miniature 99s
about an hour and a half okay so this is
Officer uho he's going to run you
through some f ofest okay make sure
you're safe to drive okay what's what's
his uh what your miss leas or okay I'll
over have a jacket in your
car okay you want to grab your jacket
it's kind of cold it is C
but your what I will thr the test okay
we just got we'll determine that okay
come on you have your jacket on no no
I'm say do you have a jacket yeah you
want to grab it that's kind of
chilly
dispatch we want to walk over here okay
just want to make sure you're safe to
drive okay safe to drive will cut you
loose no citations okay all right we're
going to stand in the front of my
vehicle all right look at me come over
here stand right there put your feet
together hands down to your side okay
and then uh where are we coming from
downtown downtown where
downtown Choco Choco and you're heading
where my house your house northeast side
northeast side okay and then how much
alcohol have you consumed today three
shots huh three shots three shots three
shots of
what vodka vodka okay put your hands
down and then can you move your hair a
little bit sorry no you're good all
right and then um any major head
injuries any problems with your eyes no
do you wear contact glasses no okay do
you have any contacts on right now no
okay all right what I'm going to have
you do um Miss is just keep your head
straight okay you see the tip of my
finger the tip follow that with your
eyes only okay you're not going to move
your head you're asking me to do a big
task right now I'm party okay okay I'm
sorry no no you're good don't worry I'm
no I'm like so slow sorry all right I'll
be slow with you you okay all right just
keep your head straight okay do you see
the tip of my finger yes follow that
with your eyes only okay you're not
going to move your head do you
understand that okay kind of yeah try to
keep your eyes open okay
okay keep your head straight I can't why
can't you I told you cuz I'm
like well I mean I I don't want I don't
want to tell you that zip zip up your
jacket for me please sorry no you're
good zip it up
ew do you see all my hair is that your
extensions yes I told you I was like so
for a
reason okay sorry okay all right just
put your feet together hands down to
your side like this like this like that
right there okay all right just keep
your head straight
okay turn on to left
you're asking a big task you're doing
it look over here my
finger over
here just keep following I'll let you
know and
stop
my ass feels like it's about to get
frostbite
you're well you have a jacket I don't
and it's cold he both huh you're in
thermals I'm not actually I don't have
thermals no
no stop keep keep your character okay
okay I'm
sorry
all right walk over here for
me stand right here for me where my
light is right and then face that way
all right put your feet together hands
down to your side all right all right
Miss um do you have any problems with
your feet legs anything going to stop
you from turning no no okay can you
imagine a straight line in front of you
no I mean I'm asking you to imagine a
straight line I yeah yeah you're asking
a super
oh can you can you imagine a straight
line okay yes yeah okay put your left
foot on top of that line and then put
your right foot in front of your left
foot touch your heel to toe touch your
heel to toe right there hands down to
your side put your right foot in front
of your left foot hands down to your
side touching you're not touching I know
I'm cold well I'm cold too okay I'm
going to be out here with you I have 30
lbs of gear yeah okay okay all right
hands down to your side all right this
line is going to be about the width of
your about the width of your shoe okay
I'm seeing you wear boots are you
comfortable wearing walking in those
boots you don't feel comfortable walking
in those boots no I'm cold well I'm cold
too okay no you're not that cold I am
cold actually I am okay but I'm out here
with you okay sir what if you're trying
to arrest me please just arrest I'm I
told you that I'm not trying to arrest
you okay I'm make I want to ensure that
you're safe to drive I'm not you're not
safe to drive no why because I drink you
drink yeah okay do you want to do these
tests no you don't want to do any of
these tests how about I run some
alternative testing which you don't have
to walk or
balance I don't okay I will call an Uber
I will get my friend a uber and I will
get my as Uber okay so you're saying you
do not want to do these tests no okay do
you want to do some alternative testing
just some numbers no counting some
numbers do you want to do that no you
want to do anything no okay we're going
to walk over here for me walk to the
front of my vehicle to the front
all right just face my vehicle and put
your back for
me me your hands I'm pick up your jacket
okay yes ma'am can can even maintain
your
balance okay and you and you smell like
alcohol
okay okay separate your feet from me
separate your feet step back a little
bit separate your feet separate your
feet right there do you have anything
pox sck you poke me
no really yeah I got a pure
you try to
move anything your
bro no no okay we're going to walk over
your f
right I have a seat for
me put your foot in
there okay it is uh 2:03 in the morning
okay
man are you really going to do that to
me yeah I don't I don't I mean we're not
here out here to play games you I mean
you want to keep you want to keep you
safe you want to keep the public that
you're driving around safe okay so if
you feel like you you're not supposed to
be driving cuz you drank too much just
like how you told me
then how how how would you want me to
let you go and
drive okay because there's like a lot
more other people what do you mean more
other people okay I'm going to read you
something okay just pay attention okay
all right listen to me I'm about to tell
you something important you're under
arrest for driving while under the
influence of intoxicated liquor and or
drugs the New Mexico ply cin act
requires you to submit to a breath test
to determine the alcohol content of your
blood after you take our test you have
the right to choose an additional
independent test if you choose to take
this additional independent test you
have the right to a reasonable
opportunity to arrange for physician a
licensed nurse or laboratory technician
or technologist who employed by a
hospital or physician of your own choice
to perform an additional chemical test
the cost of this additional test will be
paid by the law enforcement agency which
is a New Mexico State Police do you do
you agree to take our test which I'm
asking for a breath test okay taking for
a breath test yes okay
yeah right open your mouth for me open
your mouth open your mouth all I'm
making sure there's nothing in your
mouth that's it pick up your tongue okay
anything in your mouth other your teeth
and your tongues no okay have a seat put
your foot in there put your foot in
there I've been I've been respectful
with you so I'm asking just respectful
back okay I have I haven't treated you
in any way okay I have been too I know
you have I'm but when I ask you to put
your feet in there I expect you to
listen to me okay all right now I'm
going to give you another respect do you
there's anything in the vehicle that you
want to take with you no your phone
wallet or anything like
that huh is your phone in there there's
my phone that's what I'm saying do you
want me to take that with you wait hold
on what am I getting rest for uh DWI
like I explained to you okay really yes
it's 205 right now mous detction cleared
okay so again is there you want me to
take your phone a wallet or
anything
huh okay just relax brief no I okay give
me give me a second give me a second I'm
going to come back and talk to you okay
no
I'm relax how's it going officer P for
state police officer P for state police
there's for sub you serving all over the
place you change Lan twice without
turning your signal you have your J
license proen chance
regation did you had anything train
[Music]
tonight how much you had to drink
tonight
man how much you had a drink tonight
[Music]
man huh not very much what is not very
much very
much you have my
li where you coming
from uh and Old
Friends
you have registration
[Music]
Insurance look up
online minute yeah so where are you
coming
from okay where are you coming from uh
where are you
heading okay just give me a few I'll
have you right
back all right man so what I want you do
this go ahead and step out of the car
I'm I'm going to make sure you're okay
to drive okay I'm going to do some tests
and if you're okay to drive you're okay
I'll let you go okay go ahead and take
off your hands from your pocket do you
have any weon any weon anything on
you okay go ahead and take off your
glasses for me put it right here for me
BL without my glasses you know so I'm
checking your eyes so do you have any
problem have you ever had an inj injury
or anything with your eyes always always
what is it I can't see with a lot of
lights
incoming okay so go ahead and stand
right over here for me just stand right
here face me it's stand right here for
me man face you and face you just put
your hands on your side okay legs
together just like that so follow the
tip of my finger with your eyes and eyes
only okay with my eyes my eyes only yes
tip of your finger yes with a light
shining my eyes which is bad for my
eyesight I'm I'm not putting I'm not
shining at your eyes man okay I'm
shining on your chest so I can see your
eyes okay still really bad but
okay so just your eyes okay man don't
move your head so just face me like that
and then move your eyes like that okay
okay
[Music]
are you cold I sure am it is cold out it
sure is sorry I don't mean to distract
you okay cuz you're shaking too I really
am it's really cool and I hate
I hate gold too just one more time
okay no it's okay all right okay okay
sorry it's
okaying so how much you had to drink man
not as much as You' think
okay I'm having a rough night please
just let me know what's going on I swear
to
God what's going
on so I'm going do another test walk and
turn okay I'm going demonstrate it for
you you're going to do it next okay so
can you imagine this white a straight
line right here can I imagine a yeah
it's just imagin line okay yeah okay
sure so go ahead and put your left foot
on that imaginary line for
me right foot heel to
toe hands on your side but it's crazy it
sure is so right if it was in the shower
different yeah so right foot go ahead
and Heel To Toe to your left foot just
like that all right just stay right
there until I tell you to okay all right
first of all I can't shave in the shower
one foot just you know all right without
shaving yes Ma
so I'm going demonstrate it again and
then you're going to do it
okay 549 come show me 10 six
Fields okay so like I
said I I get it man I'm cold too but I'm
going demonstrate it just as soon as you
as long as you do it okay so you're
going to take nine series stop heel to
toe you're going to count your steps
alloud okay I'mma take three you're
going to take nine okay I'm going to
demonstrate it for you okay it's going
to look like this one 2 3 once you take
your nine steps you're going to make a
turn serious step just like this and
then Heel To Toe one two three I took
three how many you going to take nine
nine all right ma'am do you have any
question for me all right when you
ready
uh-huh yeah
yeah
4 5 6 7 8 9 no that's good all right man
next test it's going to be one leg stand
okay Ma so what I want you to do is
worse on that I just told you can't even
shave one leg on the shower so it's only
going to be 30 seconds okay just do it
as best as you can I'll I'll double
check okay man you promise yeah promise
okay all right man put your feet again
together go ahead and pick up your
whichever foot you want whichever leg
it's up to you six Ines parallel to the
ground it's going to look like this okay
you know what parallel means right yes
okay so ex just parallel to the ground
you're going to count 1 1,000 2 1,000 3
1,000 until I tell you to stop do you
understand okay if you do drop your foot
pick pick it back up and then just keep
counting okay that doesn't matter no it
don't it I'm like I say it's just a test
um cuz if you feel my new caps right now
please feel my new cap okay it's it's
they shaking to death okay just so you
know like a chihuahua yes ma'am
like I said the best do it the best you
can okay manam do you have an equation
for
me do you understand it
this you do all right go
ahead I'm
sorry straight in the eyes
okay 30 seconds whenever you're ready
just count out loud until I I tell you
to a sub
okay
go
ahead put your hands on your side go
ahead side yeah no
balance so no balance try to have a
balance man do it do it as best as you
can
man maybe my
right I don't know
okay I suck at shaving in the shower
though yes man you have no idea
count of loud okay 1 2 3 4 5 6
79 10 11
[Music]
14 sorry it's okay man
wor all right man that's okay that's
enough man so go ahead and face my
unit face my unit for
me all right put your hands on the
back so I'm not I don't want to hurt you
okay are you arresting me yes
ma'am give me other h
take want to take this
off come over
here sure is okay actually come back
sorry about that come back right here
they have anything on you
man
no okay
spread your
[Music]
feet
4 you have any pocket
[Music]
here 5.9 come can you send the police X
please okay come over here I'm already
[Music]
going
go ahead take a seat for
me all right man I'm going to read you
something important
okay 39 I'm sorry your half of course
thank you okay friend lives where I live
on I didn't say I where does your friend
live that that where you're coming from
off I live off SE
Street okay where where are you coming
from I'm coming from my friend and
that's
on yeah give me your license please yes
pleas all right do you have insurance on
the vehicle
yes what is this that is my license
that's my registration okay what I asked
for it's my
you can tell her that you're you're not
going to deal with something else right
now I can't deal with someone else right
now because I'm fucking pulled over all
right you have the
insurance again what I ask for my entr
okay and where's that at it's right
here
all right have that back you can put all
that back all right I'll take I'll start
on that here's the deal all right put
the phone down all right all right I
believe that based off all right the way
I'm looking at you right now you're
you're sling your speech all right your
eyes are droopy all right they're a
little bloodshot watery all right you're
you're your fine motor functions all
right you're you're having trouble
following simple okay that's fine all
right you you are you already admitted
that you had something to drink tonight
all right so I'm going ask you do are
you willing to submit uh to F sobriety
test and ensure that you're not impaired
yeah okay I'm going to have you step out
for
me do you have pants or something that
you can put on Well ma'am put pull pull
that down all right I didn't ask you to
do that all right okay P do you have
pants that you can put on no okay all
right we're going to step over here for
me can I put some pants on what was that
can you put some pants on do you have
pants my mom all I understand all right
you're going to stand right here for
me all right I know it's cold I'm going
trying to get these done as fast as
possible all right you just got to
follow directions yes sir all right yes
sir all right move your hair out of your
face all right you going to stand just
like that yes sir hands down on your
side all right good to go move your hair
out of your face for me the the hair
that's literally in your eyes pull it
down there you go all right stand like
that all
right all right do you have any head
injuries no do you have any medical
issues all
right do you have anything that would
prevent you from following simple
directions or any any issues with your
eyes do you wear contacts nope all right
do you wear glasses nope all right do
you see this light right here what color
is it the blue all right point to it for
me all right wait I'm going to have you
do you put your hand now all right
you're going to follow with your eyes
and your eyes only all right put your
hands down on your side like I told you
right you do not move your head do you
understand that yes sir all
right all right don't move your head
keep your head just right where it's at
right now all
right don't move your head all right you
are all right keep your head look head
straight right that all right do not
move your head just your eyes and your
eyes only all
right all
right well what are you following the
light are you this I the light like I
told you this light right here that's
directly in front of you yes sir all
right all right same thing up and down
okay
mhm
all
right the next sh I'm going to have you
do is to walk and turn okay when I have
you do put your left foot right down on
this line right here right down
here yep facing the
vehicle all right facing that
vehicle facing that vehicle right right
here that's right there face that
vehicle with your whole body all right I
understand I understand put your left
foot on the line all right your right
foot directly in
front no hold on I'm explain something
okay all right back up a little bit put
your left foot on that white line your
right foot directly in
front just like that hands down at your
side all right you're going to remain in
that position until I tell you to move
do you understand yeah okay when I tell
you to you're going to take nine Heel To
Toe steps looking down at your feet
counting out loud 1 2 three and so on
until you get to nine when you get to
that ninth step you're going to take a
series of small turns coming back down
the line taking nine Heel To Toe steps
looking down at your feet counting out
loud 1 2 3 and so on until you get to
nine do you understand that yeah all
right I'm going to do a brief
demonstration all right not not yet I
didn't tell you to start you're not
going to start till I tell you go back
into that position I told you to get in
just like that all
right reverse left foot down right foot
directly in front heel the toes touching
heel the toes touching touch your no go
back put your left foot
down your right foot directly in
front Ju Just Like That heel and Toes
touching thank you all right when you do
you're going to take nine heeler toe
steps all right I'm going to demonstrate
briefly for you all
right one two three and so on until you
get to ninth when you get to that ninth
step you're going to take a serious
small turn just like this keeping that
lead Lane Lead Foot on the line going
back down the line count out one two
three and so on until you get the N all
right when you start the test do not
stop all right continued motion all the
way down those series of small turns and
all the way back do you understand that
yeah all right you may
begin four
five you want turn around now just like
I instructed
one okay all right the next test I'm
going to have you do is the one leg
stand all
right peel the toes touching just like
that hand down each side all right when
I tell you to you're going to pu up
either left either leg left or right it
doesn't matter which one you're going to
hold it approximately 6 in off the
ground looking down at your feet keeping
your foot parallel you're going to count
1,1 1,2 13 all right do not stop the
test until I tell you to stop okay all
right you're going to keep counting
until I tell you to stop all right like
I said either foot doesn't matter which
one left or right going to hold it about
6 Ines off the ground you don't have to
do it right now all right 1001 1002 13
and so on do you understand yeah
one two what do you no not yet when I
tell you to start
okay
okay all
right begin one two hold it six in and
hands down at your
side all right you can
stop you can
stop all right I'm going have you one
last test I'm going to have you come
over here walk forward face the face in
front of that vehicle right
there all right put your hands behind
your back put your hands behind your
back all right you're under arrest for
DUI all
right no yes ma'am okay one 9 three 2 3
4 5 6
cool what are you
doing I don't know I guess I don't
know3 do you have pants in the vehicle
yeah we're going to get those all right
can I call my husband 15 on that female
signal one can I call my husband all
right uh no you can call him when you
get to the jail please let me call my
husband I'm not hold on no I'm going to
call my husband you're going to
jail can I please call my
husband we're going to get you some
pants all
right watch your head watch
your can I call can I call my husband
all right do you have anything in you or
on you no I need to call my husband okay
please let me call my husband hold
on
man that's cool try what she got panties
on right there yeah she lifted it up and
exposed herself to me why why what Char
with that but okay uh cuz I asked her do
she have pants on and she just
completely I'm grab her phone her wallet
I think I think those are sweats
yeah the the did she say why she didn't
have pants on no okay
I mean it is way too cold for normal
people to be out and about without pants
on she ain't got no pants that's what we
were wondering like cuz we didn't think
she had shoes on and we didn't think she
had pants on she don't she chose the
wrong like the wrong day not to be
wearing pants they'll give her a
jumpsuit pants she chose the wrong day
not to wear pants not to wear shoes Okay
do you raise your hand for me yes sir
for everything we there rest your
knowledge yes sir all right sign the fin
line please yes sir thank you thank you
ma'am what for yes ma'am about to catch
another charge do you
understand is she SLI her
cuff step
out you're pushing my nerves step
out step out I'm stepping out turn
around yeah turn
around what did I do you slipped your
cff that's what you did you know Escape
is no did I what yeah okay okay okay
okay okay what so all right all right
good to go don't worry I'm going show
your vehicle now I was going to give you
an option to call it you want to you
want to you no I don't I don't stop
please please stop no I didn't turn
around turn around stop no
stop no stop please please please stop
please please please please please
please stop I did not relax relax pleas
relax face the vehicle relax turn around
don't look at
me you SLI these C again I'm going
charge
you is there someone that can come get
this vehicle my mama where she live at
she's on the Stewart Street mhm all
right I'mma grab what all do you need
out of that car everything well you
everything you're going to get your
wallet all right cell phone cell that's
all you need that's all you need wallet
and cell phone all right watch your
head I'm going to tell you this one time
you will stop hitting this car do you
understand I do not I do not repeat
myself stop hitting this car watch your
[Applause]
knes stop stop kicking your feet like a
little
child good lord it's too cold for this
yeah just hop in your car or hop my car
it's up all right I'm going to see I'm
going to have her see get her a
call all right Alexis please take home
me home all listen I'm I didn't do
anything listen I'm giving you one
opportunity right now listen what is
your mom's number my mom's number is 501
314 hold on 85 85
five five what 8 5 uhh
one 5 can I get my phone ma'am listen to
me what I don't have my number if I
can't call her what you don't what is
her number you just gave it to
me what is your what is your mom's
telephone number
listen tell me now so if not I'm going
to have to tow your vehicle I don't want
to tow it I'm trying to work with you
here okay
I don't know my number I don't know my
number you don't know it by heart 501
uh-huh
50101 I don't know my number if you can
get my get my phone I give you I give
you her number you can give me my fault
all right watch out it's my fault Alexis
relax relax I yes you just asked me to
grab it okay you're right did he not
yeah I did I
did
to get
the what's your
code
1964 all right 1964
what I put 1964 in there what's the last
two 06
54 54 06 yeah 03 06
0364 it's not working and your phone
just locked all right
1964 that's not what you did and your
phone's locked for a minute all
right get in here please it's it doesn't
I'm not sitting here playing games with
you you're not you are all right get to
go no I'm not no give me my pH please
watch yourself no
1964 1964 what my phone number 03 1964
03 my phone number I don't need your
phone number I need you to unlock the
phone in 1 minute I it's locked because
you put it in too many times wrong you
don't even you're that's how intoxicated
you are right now you don't even realize
that yeah how you put yourself in danger
you put everyone else's lives in danger
sorry I understand that I don't think
you're a bad person understand that okay
I believe you made a mistake I hope you
learn from this mistake all right I did